[Musik]
misten hoch
emma ist eine jane austen verfilmung des
gleichnamigen romans von den osten eine
sehr widerständige helden keine sehr
sympathisches personen diese emma und
verfilmt wurde das ganze von einer
debütantin muss man sagen nämlich eine
regisseurin namens the wild die kennt
man bisher noch nicht
und the wild hat bisher hauptsächlich
als fotografin tätig hat mit musikern
zusammengearbeitet hat auch musikvideos
gemacht und man merkt diesem film an
dass sie wirklich einen ganz genauen
blick hat also dass sie wirklich ihr
ganzes set immer unter kontrolle hat in
jeder minute
was passiert im hintergrund wirklich gar
nichts zufällig einen gasthof dieser
größe hat immerhin war sein und wo es
anwalt soll gibt da gibt es auch einen
ball
man kann ich leben über zu ganz am
anfang denkt man vielleicht bleibt das
ganze so ein bisschen auf der oberfläche
aber die gute nachricht ist dass sich
der film zusammen mit seiner hauptfigur
praktisch immer weiter aufwärmt und
immer zugänglicher und immer
menschlicher wird es sind fälle bekannt
von von jungen menschen viele viele
monate erfolgreich ohne jegliche
tanzveranstaltung ausgekommen sind und
das uran körper oder gast aber jemand
jemand der das vergnügen herumzuwirbeln
einmal entdeckt hat
der muss schon
fertig sein wenn er mich doch mehr war
wir sehen am jahr tyler die eine junge
englische schauspielerin und die ist
eben diese der widerständige ma es gab
vorher schon verfilmungen mit gott porco
das war glaube ich die letzte aus den
90er jahren
und da wurde eben wahrscheinlich auch um
die hauptdarstellerin zu verkaufen sehr
auf gefällig gebürstet und das macht
dieser film nicht um das halte ich ihn
sehr zugute also anja taylor darf
wirklich einfach unsympathisch sein und
darf skeptisch sein und darf das
vermögen verwöhnte balk sein dass diese
immer ja auch tatsächlich immer wieder
ist und das ist glaube ich wirklich was
neues das man so einen schönen
kostümfilm hat mit einem romantischen
thema das ist eine jane austen
verfilmung ist aber die heldin darf
einfach kratzbürstig sein sie muss uns
nicht gefallen wie so gut aus wie ist
wirklich haus begrüßt die neuigkeiten
es gab ja jetzt wirklich eine ganze
reihe kostümfilme also eben little women
oder gefeiert und ich glaube dass die
alle so ein bisschen also little women
vielleicht noch am wenigsten der ist
noch am gefährlichsten eigentlich hat
auch die gefährlichsten heldinnen aber
dass man doch wie ein bisschen versucht
auch so die seltsamkeit einer anderen
epoche durchaus stehen zu lassen also
die müssen nicht immer in die gegenwart
geholt werden und irgendwie nett sein
und so sondern ich glaube man man lässt
diese epoche in ihrer ganzen absurdität
oder in ihrer ganzen fremdheit erst mal
so stehen also es gab auch in der
favorite wirklich ganz ganz absurdes
sehen was damals anruf eben als
amüsement durchging
wenn man vergisst die pistole zu laden
wird sie geräuschvoll abgefeuert aber es
löst sich kein schuss
ein großer spaß findest du nicht auch
und ich glaube so ein bisschen in diese
richtung funktioniert immer auch also
gerade was die kostüme angeht die sind
nicht immer schön die sind nicht immer
gefällig und das ist nicht immer alles
super feminine rüschen wo man denkt ach
wie romantisch
und dann diese kleider sind durchaus
auch steif und unbequem aber was
wirklich interessant es ist der ton weil
jane austen wenn man sie so einfach eins
zu eins ab filmt er gibt ja immer
wunderschöne romantische filme und da
kommt aber immer eine ebene überhaupt
nicht zu tragen und dass es dieser sehr
ironische ton von jane austen liebe
hochgeschätzte freunde
wir sind heute hier in münchen in dieser
zeit von großer menschlicher und schuld
unschuld
ich finde dass in dieser verfilmung
durch ganz kleine sachen durchblicke
durch gesten
es gibt zum beispiel rund um den fahrer
herum der sich immer beschwert dass es
zieht gibt es immer so eine wirklich so
eine choreografie und so ein theater an
bediensteten die immer ständig
irgendwelche schirme um ihn herum
aufstellen damit es eben nicht mehr
zieht und diese schirme sind
ich bin auch dramaturgisch immer wieder
eine rolle weil sie den raum abgrenzen
und begrenzen und das ist man mit so
ganz kleinen mitteln wirklich sehr sehr
geschickt gemacht und sehr geschickt
choreografiert und dadurch kommt diese
ironie immer eigentlich viel stärker
heraus die ich bin den bisherigen jane
austen verfilmung oder in vielen davon
bis auf die von anni sinn und
sinnlichkeit ist da wirklich auch ein
weiteres sehr sehr gutes beispiel
aber sonst habe ich die immer so ein
bisschen vermisst und das wurde immer
sehr auf romantik getrimmt das macht
dieser film hat nicht wie geht es ihnen
ich kam um zu gratulieren gratulieren
die woche ganz herzlicher tag wie war
ihnen ein zumute wäre schluchzt am
meisten
wir waren die charmantesten gäste alle
wann herausgeputzt keine trainer- und
kam ein langes gesicht waren sie also
einerseits ist das so ein film für ich
glaube menschen die die wirklich gerne
ästhetische filme anschauen wie auch
vielleicht sich für fotografie oder für
kunst interessieren weil man wirklich
das gefühl hat jeder einstellung ist wie
gemalt
das ist wirklich bemerkenswert in diesem
film und man merkt dass regisseurin auch
wirklich anders
die fotografin ist und wirklich große
sets und auch nur durch fotografien
gemacht hat und so weiter
aber natürlich ist es auch was für leser
von historischen romanen die vielleicht
schon mehrere jane austen verfilmung
gesehen haben und diese jetzt natürlich
wirklich nicht verpassen sollten weil da
kommt was neues finde ich und das ist
bemerkenswert und das ist nicht nur
einfach so runter verfilmt sondern
dieser film hat selber was dazu zu sagen
und versucht diesen stoff wirklich
ernsthaft in die heutige zeit zu bringen
[Musik]
du musst dich unter der telefax und
simone angesehene bereitschaft
[Musik]